it's July 12 1979 and the Chicago White
Sox are set to play the Detroit Tigers
in the second game of a doubleheader the
baseball park had a capacity of 44,000
people but that night 55 thousand
spectators showed up this event is
remembered not because of the game but
because of what happened right before it
it was disco demolition night the main
attraction the disco demolition
spearheaded by morning radio man Steve
Dahl and his anti disco army called the
insane coho lift that felt good Steve
Dahl a disco hating radio DJ thought
it'd be hilarious to blow up hundreds of
disco records in center field much to
the dismay of those that approved this
stunt about 7,000 people bum rush the
field inciting a riot the baseball game
never happened this moment went down in
history as the night disco died but it
didn't within just a few years
Chicago's youngest music producers and
DJs would completely reinvent dance
music by playing those disco records
over hard-hitting electronic drum
machines in the city that disco died it
was reborn as house music and within a
decade it would travel the globe Frankie
Knuckles one of the godfathers of house
called it discos revenge
in 1989 James vulture was working in a
record store in Manchester England
one Saturday someone came in and just
went I want the record that goes why the
song they wanted to hear was right on
time by black box obviously in this club
is mine it was the most important record
that they'd ever heard this happened at
the tail end of an underground drug
induced movement in the UK dubbed the
second Summer of Love some very clever
people suddenly realized that they could
halt a massive sound system out to a
field and get 20,000 paying punters to
come and see it
in 1989 right on time went from being an
underground house hit to spending six
weeks at number one on the pop charts by
the end of the year it was the
best-selling single in the UK
right on time represents some of the
genres biggest influences from the
vocals and piano to the drums each
element of the song helps tell the story
of how house music came to be right on
time black box Top of the Pops - BBC -
starting first song now
[Music]
this is black box performing right on
time on Top of the Pops England's iconic
music show despite what this performance
might have you believe this person isn't
actually singing she's lip-synching to
one of the most widely sampled disco
records in house lolita Holloway's love
sensation Lolita Holloway was a gospel
singer turned disco diva from Chicago
her song love sensation was released
just a few months after disco demolition
while the track itself fared pretty well
it's the acapella released on the
12-inch single that Chicago DJ's remixed
over and over and they did it just do it
in clubs they did it on the radio WB MX
is a Chicago radio station that was home
to a legendary group of djs called the
hot mix 5 the hot mix 5 on WB MX silos
number one dance party big family at two
point seven attend these DJ's played a
pivotal role in popularizing house music
from ralphi Rosario with his rocker
rosario of audio italia record - Farley
Jack muster through the 1980s the hot
mix 5 went from remix in disco records
live on the air to playing original
house music tracks that Chicago DJ's
produced it's estimated that a million
people in Chicago tuned into their show
every Saturday night fans would record
these programs on cassettes and share
them around the world that process is
literally how I'm able to share this
recording of Farley ki3 mixing love
sensation in 1984
there's always been this association
with big diva vocals and house music so
it said no surprise to me that people
went for some of the most powerful vocal
samples that had come from the disco era
started to chop in the mountain piecing
them back together by some estimates the
love sensation was sampled nearly 300
times and while DJ's in Chicago likely
started that trend it was right on time
that made lalita's voice a house music
staple even the most die-hard
instrumental techno loving vocal hating
snobs that I know within that scene
still loved that vocal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you're listening to is the kick
drum of the roland tr-909 if there's a
defining instrument in house music it's
this drum machine it's a big chunky
beige box with proper 80s livery all
over it
you've got 16 buttons at the bottom a
series of controls for all of the actual
different drum sounds the 909 was
invented in 1983 by a guitar oak
akahoshi the founder of roland
corporation this man gave us probably by
accident machines that cost nothing but
a revolution the 909 or the nine as
lovers of it like to call it is the
successor to the 808 you probably know
the 808 as the drum machine that powers
hip hop takahashi invented that to both
used analog synthesis to generate sound
but the 909 was unique in that it's
cymbals and hi-hats were samples of real
drums there's something and especially
the open hi-hat that just whips a dance
floor into a frenzy straight away I mean
a kick is one thing but it's really that
certain like yeah that's that's a track
as much as the 909 is really iconic
today back in 1984 it was deemed a
commercial failure only 10,000 units
were actually made when the producers
were wanting to create this new type of
electronic music in Chicago most of them
are broke so they just went to the pawn
shops to see what was available and the
one thing that was nearly always
available was the poor 909 because it
just hadn't sold very well but it just
so happened to have that particular
perfect storm of the massive kick drum
the belting clap the snare drum that you
can do fantastic little rolls off and
those sloshy for five bits cymbals and
high hats that punchy sound of the 909
quickly permeated through Chicago in
even Detroit where bedroom producers
were taking inspiration from house music
and developing a genre called techno you
can think of Larry heard can you feel it
[Music]
you can think of Derrick May strings
alive you can hear it in Jack your body
the first Chicago House music song to
reach number one in the UK all the way
to early house it's actually made in the
UK like Adamski's killer if you take
away - 909 from that a lot of that
thumping drive is gone it's no surprise
then that in the opening few bars of
right on time you can hear that 909 kick
drum and there's crunchy high hats and
then the piano started and then it got
interesting
in the late-1980s different health
subgenres began to form there was acid
house developed from the song acid
tracks by Chicago producer future its
iconic sound came from the squelching
bassline of a tb-303 synthesizer there
was deep house which leaned heavily on
soulful vocal samples and spacious
synthesizers
[Music]
and then there was a tallow house which
more than any other offshoot relied on
the upbeat rhythm of a digital piano
right on time is a classic Italo house
track so much so there's a solo piano
version of the song on the 12-inch
single
[Music]
the Italians really knew how to do this
mixture of great big pianos and you add
that kind of over some diva element into
that and it became a staple in 1986
three years before right on time
Chicago's Marshall Jefferson released
move your body dubbed the house music
anthem it's this song that helped
establish how future house tracks would
incorporate piano riffs the way piano is
used in house music is very much almost
as a powerful rhythmic guitar listen to
the piano and right on time next to move
your body and you'll immediately hear
the similarities in rhythm
[Music]
the musical exchange between Italy and
Chicago might seem like a one-way street
at a low house and right on time in
particular would not have existed
without the innovations of Chicago
artists and that was met with a lot of
controversy lolita Holloway's vocal and
right on time
wasn't properly cleared when the song
was released nor was she initially
credited for it but if we rewind back to
Chicago in the early 1980s
right after disco demolition an unlikely
genre of music was taking off Italo
disco Italian disco had a massive effect
on the early house producers because
they effectively had this going before
house music had really come to the fore
and was really the new sound within the
clubs just like house the sound of Italo
disco is driven by drum machines and
synthesizers and it's this genre that
forms the link between lolita Holloway's
disco and house music take a listen to
this w BMX radio show again
[Music]
that was that Lolita Holloway acapella
you heard earlier transitioning
seamlessly into shame you were the big
sensation an Italo disco record go
through any Chicago house DJ set in the
1980s and you'll see them littered with
Italo disco records and that influenced
what those DJs would go on to produce
take the Italo disco song dirty talk
released in 1982 that opening baseline
and arpeggiated synth is mirrored in a
lot of house tracks including the 1986
classic you are loved by Frankie
Knuckles and Jamie principled by 1990
house music was a global music genre
artists from the UK to Australia were
filling dance floors with the 909 kick
drum and that was almost inevitable from
its inception in Chicago house music was
always a cross cultural phenomenon what
happened when ride on time came forward
is that you had the kind of perfect
storm of a great big monster club sound
with a vocal that a a load of people
already knew and B sounded powerful you
could almost put it as an actual pivotal
point in house music and say from that
point it all just blew wide open
[Music]